la france fait-elle nécessaires pour
protéger ses lanceurs d'alert françoise
nicolas ancien fonctionnaire du
ministère des affaires étrangères en
afrique se bat depuis des années pour
faire reconnaître ce statut après avoir
traversé un véritable enfer en 2008 elle
est affectée à l'ambassade de france de
cotonou au bénin au sein du service de
coopération culturelle consciencieuse
méthodique elle d'y repérer rapidement
un système de création de factures au
culte imputé sur un budget de l'état
plus de cent mille euros auraient ainsi
été détournés puis comme ses 2 600
tonnes sont devenus de plus en plus
nombreux au fil des mois
je m'en suis inquiété dans un premier
temps gelé signalé en interne auprès de
ma nouvelle hiérarchie voilà qui n'a
rien fait et au bout de trois mois
j'ai écrit à l'administration centrale à
mon correspondant gestionnaire pour lui
exposer la situation et lui demander ce
que je devais faire
je n'ai jamais eu de réponses alors elle
entend des rumeurs menaçante se sent
harcelé par ses collègues et le 14
janvier 2010 un incident d'une violence
inouïe se produit elle dit avoir été
frappée et étranglée par une de ses
collègues béninoise où j'étais en train
de mourir sur l'effet de la
strangulation un moment donné le cerveau
à disjoncter j'étais en train de me suis
vu mourir et à ce moment là un agent
d'entretien alertés par le bruit est
entré dans en courant dans le bureau a
réussi à arracher mon agresseur à mon
cou françoise nicolas j atteins
inconsciente avant d'être ramenés dans
un cabinet médical et en juillet 2015 un
juge d'instruction français reconnaîtra
la qualification de tentative de meurtre
mais l'incroyable se produit la collecte
de françoise nicolas porte plainte en
premier l'ambassadeur s'entretient avec
le ministère de la justice béninoise
l'assaillante ayant tué un enfant avec
le beau frère du président béninois
cette affaire suscite l'émoi dans les
cercles du pouvoir
françoise nicolet rapatrié d'urgence en
france au nom de l'intérêt général de
l'état français l'ambassadeur ne veut
pas ébruiter la faire et il n'y aura pas
d' enquête
l'idée c'était de se débarrasser de moi
de m'écarter depuis l'ancien
fonctionnaire se dit placardisé en
france abandonné par le ministère qui ne
lui a pas accordé de protection
fonctionnelle
le député insoumis ugo bernalicis qui
l'a auditionné à demander des comptes au
ministère au quai d'orsay on dément
formellement
aucun document ou élément matériel
n'avait été retrouvé à l'administration
centrale ou dans les archives du service
culturel à cotonou pourtant ces mails
d'alert nous ont été transmis le
ministère arc également que françoise
nicolas aurait dû faire le signalement
sur une plateforme dédiée
mais en réalité elle n'y a plus accès
n'étant plus fonctionnaires le ministère
statut surtout sur l'absence d'éléments
permettant d'établir le lien entre ces
événements survenus au bénin et le
service réaction d'hugo bernalicis la
réponse du ministère des affaires
étrangères me laisse pantois tant sur
les lanceurs d'alert que sur la
situation de françoise nicolas toujours
aucune prise de conscience des problèmes
systémiques
il est temps de faire évoluer le cadre
légal protégeant les fonctionnaires et
les lanceurs d'alerté moi ce que
j'attends c'est l'application des lois
ni plus ni moins ni plus ni moins
fondamentalement les il est établi que
j'ai signalé en interne des
détournements de fonds publics que j'ai
été menacé que j'ai été agressé sur mon
lieu et mon temps de travail que j'ai
été sanctionné
les faits sont là comme d'autres
lanceurs d'alert françoise nicolas se
retrouve seul démunis ignoré par l'état
malgré des informations accablantes
jacques toubon ancien défenseur des
droits a clôturé son dossier et la cour
d'appel de nantes a validé en mars 2021
l'arrêté des affaires étrangères qui
avait radié la diplomate de leurs
effectifs
le quai d'orsay n'a pas répondu à notre
demande d'information et une chef de
plomb demeurent dans cette affaire entre
la france et le bénin qui rappelle
tristement l'âge sombre de la
françafrique